England 1953 in Cambridge and London
scientists are figuring out the
structure of DNA meanwhile in Oxford a
researcher named James Gowens is trying
to solve another biological puzzle The
Mystery of the disappearing lymphocytes
he knows that these small cells flood
into the bloodstream continuously from
the lymphatic system but where do they
go and what do they do
to find out Gowens adds a radioactive
label to some cells and injects them
into rats he discovers that the cells
move from the blood to lymph nodes
through lymphatic vessels and back to
the blood again the cells are not
disappearing they are circulating again
and again
today we know that these lymphocytes are
the B and T cells that are a vital part
of our immune system
by continuously moving around the body
they learn to recognize infections and
help us fight them to understand how
let's follow one T Cell on its Journey
right now it's in the bone marrow
beginning its change from a stem cell to
a more specialized cell next it travels
to the thymus where it matures into one
of two types of T Cell this cd8 T cell
has been trained and is ready to work
but because it hasn't yet been activated
we call it a naive T cell
it moves to the bloodstream then
squeezes through a special blood vessel
and enters a lymph node lymph nodes
filter fluid and proteins from
surrounding tissues the T Cell scans
around looking for pieces of virus or
bacterial proteins
nearby a virus has infected the skin a
dendritic cell grabs an infected cell
and travels to the lymph node where it
presents chopped up pieces of viral
protein called peptides to the T cell
fortunately this T cell has a receptor
that recognizes one of the peptides
kicking off an immune response the
activated T Cell starts dividing some of
the new cells become effector T cells
special homing receptors tell them to go
to the skin where they kill infected
cells others become memory T cells some
hang around the infection site others
keep moving around the body they are all
ready to kick-start the immune response
if they spot this virus again
which brings us back to the observation
that gallons made that T cells keep
recirculating around the body why
each T Cell expresses a unique receptor
that can only recognize a very few
peptides to increase the chance of a T
Cell encountering a peptide that matches
its receptor it must keep moving and
searching if all the T cells with their
different receptors do this the immune
system has a good chance of detecting
anything that might cause a problem